throughout the case we didn't believe
that we were getting a fair trial and
this decision confirms that suspicion
and we will be presenting evidence of
that unfairness to the appeals court the
NYPD's policing tactic known as stop and
frisk is an extremely divisive topic
with national implications
supporters say it is a necessary tool
for crime prevention opponents contend
that it has led to routine wholesale
police harassment of young black and
Latino men an opinion held by Judge
Shira Shipman who in rendering her
decision in the federal class-action
lawsuit floyd versus new york declared
stop and frisk as practiced by the NYPD
under police commissioner ray kelly to
be unconstitutional Sunita Patel an
attorney who litigated the case for the
Center for Constitutional Rights
explains the NYPD stop and frisk
practices are violation of New Yorkers
fourth and Fourteenth Amendment rights
the New York Police Department has
systematically stopped and frisked New
Yorkers without reasonable suspicion
that's required under the Constitution
and in violation of equal protection
rights which means that the stops are
based on race or national origin
according to the United States Supreme
Court the police department has
Authority and has power to stop and
frisk individuals who they believe are
engaged in the criminal activity or have
committed a crime it is bedrock and
fundamental principle that stop and
frisk is allowed what we are trying to
achieve is constitutional policing
problem with the New York Police
Department is that you have generalized
suspicion
please officers testified in this case
and supervisors testified in this case
that young male black is sufficient
grounds to stop someone that is just not
individualized and it's not reasonable
suspicion Heather McDonald a fellow at
the Manhattan Institute has written
extensively in defense of stop and frisk
and rejects the notion that the policy
is in any way racially biased the
advocates complain about the number of
stops they complain about the racial
disparities and stops they have never
suggested an absolute number or what
they think these racial stop ratio
should be given what the crime rates are
I would love to have the
step up and actually provide a number
the demographics of crime are not
proportionately distributed among
different racial and ethnic groups
blacks are being under stopped compared
to their crime rates blacks or 23% of
the population in New York they commit
80% of all shootings 70% of all
robberies and 66% of all violent crime
they're 53% of all stops White's are 35%
of the population they commit a little
over 1% of all shootings and 5% of all
violent crime
nobody racially profiles and the fact of
the matter is the kids and I think
they're going to get stopped so they
don't carry the gun and if you can't do
that then you know you just turn over
the streets to the criminals literally
overnight the effectiveness of stop and
frisk has come into question as data
from 2011 shows about 700 guns were
recovered from about 700,000 stops a
success rate of one tenth of one percent
still Police Commissioner Ray Kelly and
Mayor Bloomberg cite the Center for
Disease Control study stating that gun
carrying among teens is lower in New
York than in any other major American
city
but does this justify the practice it is
a misunderstanding that the only purpose
of stop question and frisk is to get
guns off the street it is also to avert
criminal behavior before it actually
becomes a crime if the officer observed
somebody trying all the door handles on
a row of cars parked on the street and
he makes it stop and questions that
person that will not result in an arrest
necessarily because there won't be
evidence on that person to support a
probable cause arrest but a crime will
have been deterred the fact that there
are not an arrest resummoned does not
mean that somebody was innocent everyone
agrees that stop and frisk is
constitutional in theory and that the
police are required to have
individualized suspicion before stopping
someone so how does the NYPD ensure
officers have a good reason the Newark
Police Department requires police
officers to complete what's called a you
f250 form officers can just check boxes
and when you have a system where there's
a check of a box and no questioning of
the facts underlying the check boxes
you have a supervisory structure that
allows unconstitutional policing to
happen in 2011 close to 50% of the stops
recorded that they were furtive
movements and that was the justification
for why the person was stopped
apparently everything that a black or
Latino young person does in this city is
considered furtive if I see a police
officer and I turn the other way and my
suspicious maybe I've been stopped
numerous times and I don't want to deal
with police that day I'm 33 they even
start about 25 times you know they will
say that it looked like it was fidgeting
or to them we supposed to always notice
them and I guess and if we just do
something like digging our pockets
that's we're putting something away or
hiding something the other day somebody
over here got killed and they come in
and arrested somebody when you have ID
he was 14 on the bike on the sidewalk
like I should be more into who did that
instead who run a bike on the Salva
that's it got nothing to do it in what
the police do is they come into a
neighborhood like this and they stop
everybody hey they don't give a damn
they don't have a description they just
think they're gonna look up and get
somebody but that's not right that's
against the Constitution which I carry
them my packet have you ever been
arrested after a stop and frisk no never
anybody you know ever been stopped and
frisked and compelled to produce
marijuana out of the pocket definitely
happens all the time you know it seems
to be the easiest way to lock us up I
guess while supporters of stop and frisk
point to lower rates of gun carrying
stop and frisk has also led to a
dramatic increase in marijuana arrests
he stopped this vision for what I had a
bag of weed on me he's going down
having marijuana in your pocket is not a
criminal activity in New York City
the police will unlawfully search
someone pull out their marijuana and
then they have grounds to arrest that
person because it's in plain view
sometimes they say hey empty your
pockets
it's not a consensual encounter we don't
have a choice they empty their pockets
and there might have been marijuana in
it
even supporters of stop and frisk are
troubled by its use as a means of making
marijuana arrests I have a big problem
with the officers who were making an
arrest for public possession of
marijuana as a result of a search that
was clearly and a misunderstanding of
power or an abuse of power New York
Police Commissioner Ray Kelly agrees
with that he's issued training orders to
confirm that that is not the intent of
the law despite commissioner Kelly's
admonition 400,000 New Yorkers have been
arrested from minor marijuana charges on
his watch with 50,000 arrests just last
year during the Floyd trial state
senator and former NYPD captain Eric
Adams testified that Commissioner Kelly
admitted to using stop and frisk to
instill fear in minority communities as
a means of keeping guns off the street
the NYPD has this very rogue attitude
that it's okay for them to engage in
unlawful behavior because they're the
biggest because they believe they are
the best
we have high-level officials who
testified in a manner that makes it very
clear that they believe that civilian
complaints around stops and frisks are
just par for the course that if officers
are out there doing their job that they
will get civilian complaints which sort
of undermines the idea of structural
accountability around police efforts
judge Finland's decision in Floyd versus
New York also names an independent
monitor of the NYPD this comes on the
heels of the City Council's recent
decision to create an NYPD Inspector
General Mayor Bloomberg whose term ends
on New Year's Day 2014 reacted strongly
to the verdict if somebody pulls a gun
and you want to get home to your family
you don't have time to say well now wait
a second the commissioner said one thing
the monitor said another and the IG said
another by that time you're dead and I'd
like to see you go to the funeral and
explain to the family
why they why their son or husband or
father is not coming home at night the
consequences are massive a fiscal
consequences she's going to saddle the
department with enormous bureaucracy
give them a federal monitor who will
impose preposterous paperwork
requirements mandates for racial data
collection number two it is going to
make officers unwilling to use their
constitutional powers of observation and
discretion to question people engage in
suspicious behavior and eventually word
is going to get out on the street that
you don't have to worry about being
stopped gun caring is going to go up
again this suit is going to spread
nationwide and it could ultimately put
the national crime drop at risk as well
stop and frisk is not going anywhere the
police department is going to use it and
in the Floyd lawsuit we're not seeking
to end the practice I have confidence
that whoever the next mayor is and
whoever the next police commissioner is
will hopefully take a different approach
that they will decide that
constitutional policing
non-discriminatory policing should be
the law of the land in the introduction
of her decision judge shenlin made it
clear that whether or not stop and frisk
is an effective crime preventer is
irrelevant what is relevant is whether
or not a policy that allows state actors
to interrupt the lives of citizens
millions of times over is constitutional
you